- Chrissy Teigen recently
tweeted that she eats
the same thing for dinner
every night which is crazy.
I think she's awesome, she is super fun.
She's hilarious, she's great on twitter,
she hosts lip sinc battle,
she has a cookbook,
so I feel like she knows what she's doing.
I wanna see what she eats
for dinner every night,
and I also want to learn
how to make it for myself.
So this morning I've
decided I'm gunna go out,
buy the ingredients, make her dinner,
and then have my coworkers try it.
The meal is really simple,
it's a full fish Branzino
cooked with garlic, olive
oil, rosemary, and lemon.
She actually has her mom cook it.
I think I'm a pretty good
cook, I'm definitely not
a chef or a professional chef, but hey,
I could be Chrissy Teigen's mom.
So I'm in a fish market now,
and they have whole Branzino's here.
Seventy five dollars.
I will say this is an expensive
thing to have every night,
but if you're Chrissy (beeps)
Teigen you can afford it
and that's dope for her.
This might be a special
occasion thing for me,
but let's go make some fish.
Okay this is grossing me out.
It's bloody, and I've never cooked
anything like this before.
There's  (beeps) eyeballs,
and I'm gunna try to clean this.
Oh god it's so slimy, ew.
So I'm just gunna cook it
the way she says she cooks it
which is covered with garlic and olive oil
and stuffed with lemon and rosemary.
There it is yay.
Once you get over the
slimy, slippery texture
of that fish it's totally fine.
I'm excited.
(jazz)
- I don't know who Chrissy Teigen is.
- I like Chrissy Teigen
I think she's funny.
- Amazing clap-backs on twitter.
- What kind of monster
can eat the same thing
for dinner every night,
like it just seems like
something only serial killers do.
- I think I could do
it with a cheeseburger.
- Mine would be ice cream.
- Oh no.
- Ew.
- It's fish.
- No thanks.
Hard pass.
- Oh wow.
- Oh.
- This looks really incredible.
- Disgusting.
- Disgusting this looks amazing.
- It's a full blown fish.
- You made this?
Wow well done Ali I'm impressed.
- So if you push shouldn't
be weirded out by this,
because like that's
what a fish looks like.
- I eat Mahara a lot, I love it,
so I'm all about the whole fish.
- Yup.
- No, I'm not gunna do this probably.
That's nasty as hell.
- This smells awesome.
This is little bits of garlic, and lemon,
and this is what rosemary?
- I hate you Ali.
- I'm gunna (talks while eating).
- Mhmm.
- Pretty good. I hate
that I could see its face.
- It's incredible.
- His eyes.
- Here.
We'll just put that over his head.
- That actually helps.
- I enjoy it.
I just don't know if I
would eat it every day,
but I love it.
- I'll eat this once a
year if I'm dating someone,
and we go to their parents house
and I have to pretend to be polite.
- Wow.
- Oh sh (beeps).
- She eats a hundred dollars
worth of fish a week?
(laughs)
(beeps)
- Goals.
- I'm gunna go. You
don't need me for this.
My final thought nah.
- you don't want anymore?
- I think we're gunna stick
with our initial mentality
of variety is the spice of life.
- I wish I could eat this every day.
- She don't know how good she got it.
Bones.
- I haven't tried it yet
so I'm gunna try it now.
I'm excited.
Mmm. Oh it's so good.
I'm really happy, I'm gunna
make this for dinner tonight.
(groovy music)
(wooshing)
(squeaking)